so who are the 1% let's imagine people
or as tall as they're rich what you'd
see is a long long line of little people
who get gradually taller so let's focus
on the richest 1% to make the cut in the
u.s. you need a household income of over
three hundred and eighty-nine thousand
dollars or a net worth of eight point
four million dollars since 2008 the
wealthiest 1% of Americans got richer
they captured 95 percent of post
recession growth but the point one
percent they tower over the rest and are
worth around 20 million dollars each the
point 0 1 percent are giants worth about
a hundred million each it's at the top
no way further up of the Titans 1,645
billionaire's whose numbers have doubled
since 2008 and finally the fiscal
overlords 80 individuals who now control
as much wealth as half the global
population
[Music]
you